that that that that will bail him out
but that doesn't look good for him hey
guys I'm off the grid for August but
fear not Chuck Todd is going away
forever and here he went out with a bang
now one thing I want to point out here
is I want to show you his this stuff has
taken a huge toll on him you know Biden
right before the 2020 election he was
right side up which in our polarized
politics is quite astonishing but look
Trump and Rudy gilani began this
campaign to try to tarnish Biden to try
to turn him into the Clinton name you
know with the with the obsession over
over the Ukraine businesses with Hunter
and it's worked his numbers now look
more like Hillary Clinton 16 than Biden
Kimberly we I'm maybe maybe abortion is
the difference there that that that that
will bail him out but that doesn't look
good for him well it won't be able to
bail him out on its own I mean to the
point about focusing on the economy yes
the economy is important the two biggest
issues is democracy and offshoot of that
is the abortion issue that is something
that should be front and center of a
message yes you have to talk about the
economy and through that he can tout the
achievements that he made and sort of
boost that incumbency value but he seems
to be campaigning in a bygone era that
he feels more comfortable in that he
wants to Wishes the world were but
that's not where we are right now we
have the former president about to go on
trial for attacking the nation's
election